so were you watching on Monday I hope
you were because guess what Oprah was
here and she revealed her newest pick
for Oprah's Book Club first on CBS this
morning we like when that happens it's
called the water dancer it's a highly
anticipated fiction debut from the
critically acclaimed author Tana hössi
Coates he has already won a National
Book Award and a MacArthur Genius grant
for his nonfiction work this is his
first novel as we know so we met Coates
on Thomas Jefferson's estate that's
Monticello where he told us that he
found inspiration for his very first
novel
[Music]
it occurred to me then that even my own
intelligence was unexceptional but you
could not set eyes anywhere on lock list
and not see the genius and its makers
genius in the hands that carved out the
columns of the portico it took Tana hasi
coats ten years to imagine the world of
enslaved people in the water dancer the
book tells the story of Hiram Walker an
exceptionally gifted man born in bondage
the title of the water dancer what does
that mean they were enslaved Africans
who literally left into the water when
they were you know being brought over to
America people would you know talk about
how you know these folks when they leave
do you know what I mean they they almost
you know seemed to dance on the waist
but water plays a key role in this book
what Hiram has is a memory the water
symbolizes it needs to not forget to
remember what happened in the great
power that that he can pull from there I
feel this is one of the few books on AHA
see that really touches on the humanity
and the emotion of slavery you know in
most cases it's painted with a
monolithic brush we don't normally have
individual stories right I wanted to
bring that into the fictional realm
I wanted to Center the emotions and the
feelings of the actual enslaved people
for his first novel Coates basis story
and Lockleys a fictional plantation
inspired by Monticello and it was in
slave labor to put up this house with
this whole house together it's a home of
President Thomas Jefferson a founding
father who himself enslaved over 600
people can't look for fright out his
history histories dirty dirty dirty it's
the muck what impacted being here in
Monticello because you came here I did
in the course of researching for this
book how did it help you with this story
well I was at a place in writing where I
had written a draft and it wasn't a good
draft says who says me in my editor so
to bring his story to life Coates came
to this excavation site is this the
imprint of a house yes exactly where
archaeologists unearth the home of an
enslaved family
and the artifacts they used I didn't
know we have marbles right here so so
what was missing before you came here
the before in the after what was missing
I think I just did they had no heart and
the characters the enslaved people
specifically warrant people you have to
get the small details of their life you
know what I mean you have to you know
again get them playing marbles you have
to get them playing the instruments and
all of that little small stuff you have
to get their humor you know what I call
that humanity exactly so what do you
envision what do you see when you look
at this even like the natural sounds we
hear right now like to insects like
little stuff like that
you know looking at the shadows and the
weight of light you know comes between
the trees like little things like that
after I left you I had it I was buzzing
and when I sat down exactly into--into
onto the page you you'd said that you're
good at two things writing and driving
and that if your writing career hadn't
worked out that you would have been a
taxi driver yeah yeah yeah I wanted to
why um
because I wasn't making it I mean I had
gotten what fired from this alternative
paper in Philly I gotten fired from the
Village Voice I gotten laid off from
Time magazine what happened in a period
of five years well you must have been
discouraged by that fired three times I
was gonna stop the writing I just didn't
think I could make a career at it it was
quite clear whatever it took to make a
career writing I probably didn't have
even like when I went to the Atlantic I
ended up being at the Atlantic for ten
years but the first two years I was like
is this is how it ends yeah like I'm
just waiting like they're gonna be like
kid you you really ain't got it so what
turned for you that you're not driving a
cab or uber or yeah live today my wife
wasn't hearing good people in your life
you know what I mean I'm lucky that I
live with a really really good and wise
person do you have any other fiction
books in there I have a time I gotta
figure out how to get them out but you
have many you do are they all in this
genre you know no but today I was
talking to one of the historians here
and I you know I was thinking what if
it's my job
just to tell the story it enslaved but
if that's everything I write from here
on because would you be satisfied with
that I think so because it's so much
like you have to remember the Puritan
enslavement is two hundred and fifty
years in this country
and up until relatively recently the
story has only been told by people who
had a vested interest in shading at a
certain way and really erasing the
stories of the enslaved now that's a
tragedy but if you're a storyteller well
that's the most beautiful thing in the
world because there's a wealth of
information that people have not
explored and it just beginning to dig
into I love talking to him he said he
had a moment when Colson white hoods
book the Underground was released he
thought oh now the story's been told
then he said he thought to himself hey
when somebody does a Western nobody says
yeah there's no more Western stories to
tell
Tonto has his book by the way is number
one on Amazon and Apple already and if
famous author once said this I've been
wondering who might fill the
intellectual void that plagued me after
James Baldwin died clearly it's Tana
hössi Coates
the person who said that was Toni
Morrison wow that's pretty good in
compared to James old when they're
getting bigger than that nascent here
I'm talk about how he works